Nancy Cain and I am the James Robeson
professor of Business Administration at
the Harvard Business School I was born
in Chicago I lived in Illinois and in
Maine and in Texas as a child went to
school in California came to Boston
twenty-five years ago for two years and
never left I think of myself as a
traveler that was how I intended to
answer the first question who are you
and I had not connected it to a
childhood that included a lot of stops
along the journey but I think living in
so many different parts of the country
and seeing so many different ways of
life probably did affect my interest in
traveling through the past and into the
present I'm very comfortable with
traveling without a set destination and
that may have something to do with being
a child that you know change school so
many times until I reach sixth grade I
think I was in a different school every
year so maybe that proclivity to travel
metaphorically is part of who I am as a
professional and as a human traveler as
a traveler on a life journey I don't
think there was a pivotal moment in my
childhood I I was asked to think about a
critical point or a juncture it would be
in my adult life and whether that that
moment or those moments you know
hearkened back or had a taproot into
older points along my childhood journey
may indeed be so but unless conscious of
them and a piece of that is is an
increasing impatience with living in the
past which i think even as a historian
being paid to do that in many ways I
have spent as a human traveler too much
time doing so I perhaps my mental
operating system mike-mike you know my
desktop if you will has just more file
folders that are closer in time to this
moment
than it does moments in my childhood my
father was a very important influence in
my life I thought for most of my adult
life thus far that he was much more
important than my mother but I think now
in my middle age and I feel like I'm
aging as I speak my mother was very
important also my father as a role model
professionally he was a philosopher and
he was a very athletic man and that was
incredibly important to me growing up
and still is he was a driven man and I
think for good and less good I took some
of my drive and my natural operating
system from him and his intensity from
my mother I actually gained more subtle
gifts an eye for the large landscape for
the large landscape of a time for the
large landscape of a moment or a
situation for the large landscape of our
lives
she's a she has a wide angle lens on her
and it took me a long time to realize
how much of that I've benefited from I
thought I would be a child psychologist
I thought I would help parents and kids
understand why young people do what they
do
ironically my father really talked me
out of majoring in psychology when I was
a sophomore at Stanford and he was a
formidable person in my life and I
followed his guide posts his signposts I
think probably with some real discord
inside me but nevertheless I followed
them